And we have made contact with the father
that lived at that residence
and are putting together
more information, information
We've also determined
there were maps drawn up the school
and detail of surveillance
entry points, etc..
We know and believe that entry
was gained through shooting through
one of the doors
is how they actually got into the school.
I want to take the time to at least say
and I won't say the victim's names.
I'll let Don say that.
But out of the six victims, three adults.
Three of those were children.
Two of them were age nine.
One was eight.
About to be nine.
All the families have been contacted.
The victims families have been contacted
as well.
My thoughts and prayers
go out to the family.
When we send our kids to school
or to any place of safety,
we expect them to live, learn and
have fun and come back
from that day days experience.
We don't anticipate things like this
And I want to say thank you
to our partners,
to Chief Swan,
to Glen Ford, to our mayor
for his support, to our federal partners.
But also,
I want to say thank you
to our first responders who got there
and immediately went in and address
the threat
of someone
that had multiple rounds of ammunition
prepared for a confrontation
with law enforcement,
prepared to do more harm
than was actually done.
And we were able
to stop the threat.
And unfortunately,
six victims
So my thoughts and prayers again,
but the prayers go to
the men and women, as I've said before.
We will not wait.
I was hoping this day would never, ever
come here in this city,
but we would never wait
to make entry
and to go in and to stop a threat,
especially when
it deals with our children.
So thank you
for not
just me there, not to anyone
I'm going to go over
the victim's names with you now.
The 39 year olds who were killed.
Evelyn Dick House,
William Kenny,
Haley Scruggs.
Three adults.
Mike Hill.
A custodian aged 61
Cynthia Peak, to my understanding,
is substitute teacher aged 61.
And Katherine Coots,
age 60.
As Chief Drake said, we have identified
the active shooter as Audrey
Elizabeth Hale,
age 28.
We'll take just a few questions
if you have any thoughts on
do you believe
that she was a former student
at the school?
Yes, we do.
If you want to address that,
one, yes, from our investigations,
tell us that she was a former student
at the school.
I don't know what grades she's
attended or grades
but we do firmly believe
she was the student there
She does
identify as transgender.
Yes.
Is there any reason to believe
the shooter
first went to the church
before going to the school?
I can't give you that information.
One.
So we know
that the minute
the calls came in, we responded
to the church.
So to the school yeah.
You have two options.
When they first got married.
So it was five
officers and immediately
went in an address.
We have video
that we're going to release.
But you can see in the video,
you can hear
gunfire going on as they're in the school
They address the threat
and take that threat down.
Chief, what do we know about the weapons?
So we know there were two
air style weapons. One a rifle.
Another was an air style pistol.
And the other was a handgun.
We believe
two of those
may have been obtained legally,
locally here.
Can you confirm
that one of the adult victims school
was what
there was some?
I don't know her
exact capacity within the school,
but it was higher up in Ashland.
Unsure,
I believe one may have been,
but I can't confirm that
any criminal and criminal history,
no history at all.
And no motive at this point.
She's been discovered in the apartment
house.
No, we have a manifesto.
We have some writings
that we're going over
that pertain to this day,
the actual incident.
We have a map
drawn out of how
this was all going to take place.
There is right now a theory of that
that we may be able to talk about later,
but it's not confirmed.
And so we'll
we'll put that out as soon as we can.
Is there any reason to believe that
how she identifies
I'm sorry.
I'm not someone's Michael.
I didn't hear you say that again, sir.
Any reason
to believe that
how she identifies
is has any motive
for targeting this woman?
We can give you that at a later time.
There is some theory to that.
We're investigating all the leads.
And once we know exactly.
We will let you know.
So what's this, a targeted attack?
It was,
you know,
not on the street
mentioned gender, man or woman.
I don't know
any history of mental illness.
At this time,
but we are looking at that
as the investigation is ongoing.
And I'm sorry
he identifies
the transgender man or woman.
Woman
the only school that was targeted.
It was the only school that was targeted.
There was another location
that was mentioned.
But because of a threat assessment
by the suspect, too much security,
they decided not to in that area
was here in Nashville.
So we're continuing
with that investigation as well.
Right now, we believe it's a lone
assailant
and we don't
anticipate any further damage
at this time.
But we're still investigating this.
Right.
What address
if you lived there with your parents?
Yes. Yes, he's
looking. Thank you.
We continue.
So the scene is going to be processed
throughout the night,
probably into tomorrow.
This is an extensive scene.
As you know, she entered the building,
which is one structure.
The church
and the school are in one building.
She entered on the lower floor.
There were shots fired on the lower floor
before she went to the upper level.
And it was on the upper level
where she was confronted
by police and killed.
So we understand the scene processing
will take place over
at least two days today and tomorrow.
And we'll have more details for you,
including the release of video
perhaps tonight,
but if not tonight, certainly tomorrow.